-Standing ovation.
-That's very nice.
Undeserved, but very nice.
-No, no.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Do you get a --
Do you get a standing ovation
when you start "Update"
on Saturday nights?
-It's in my contract.
-Yeah, okay.
-Why didn't I put it in before?
-It's been a couple years
since I had you on the show.
-I know.
-And I'll tell you
what happened.
You got married.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you very much.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You had a baby.
-I -- We had a baby.
-You had a baby. You guys --
-I did a little of it.
-Yeah, you did
a little bit of it.
Yeah.
Congratulations.
How's married life?
How's the baby?
-It's great.
He's 18 months old.
He's doing great.
He's walking, he's talking.
His favorite word is "cracker."
Same as Michael Che --
same favorite word.
[ Laughter ]
Same as his uncle.
He got it from his uncle.
-Yeah.
But he's -- he's cute.
-He's great dancing.
He's not really da--
-He's, like, running around?
-He's walking, but in place.
-You brought a photo
of your son.
-We're private, but we...
-So cute.
-Yeah, this we're --
-Can I show it?
-Yeah, I mean, it's so cute.
[ Laughter ]
It's like a mix.
You see, it's both of us.
-Yeah, it is. Yeah, yeah.
-There's a little of both of us.
And the dancing is --
the dancing's good.
-Yeah.
-We have Kenya Barris
on the show tonight.
-Oh, yeah.
-And we're talking backstage.
He cast you in
"Coming 2 America."
-That's right. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-In "Coming to America 2."
The 2 is in the middle,
so it's --
if you just say it,
it's confusing.
-Oh, that's interesting.
Yeah, you're right.
"Coming 2 America."
-Yeah, so I was --
I believe I was, basically,
the only white character
in the film.
[ Laughter ]
I think it was --
Louie Anderson came
and reprised his role,
and then it was me.
-Yeah.
-And you're not gonna believe
it, but I was a villain.
-[ Scoffs ]
-I know.
And weirdly,
I didn't have to audition.
They...
[ Laughter ]
They were just like,
"The part of 'White Villain.'
I guess we just ask Colin."
-Yeah.
-"He'll come in and do it."
And it's really crazy on --
like, when you're doing the role
because they make me do,
say horrible things.
And then at the --
you know, you're doing it,
and then when
the director yells "take,"
you have to be like,
"I'm sorry. I'm sorry."
-Yeah. "I apologize.
That was not me."
-"I'm just reading
the lines here."
-Yeah, but then when you
improvise in character
and it works,
you feel even worse.
-Don't do that.
-You know? Oh, my God.
-When you do "Weekend Update,"
are there some times you have,
the show's off for two weeks
or whatever that --
and you miss a story,
do you get mad?
You're like, "Oh, I would have
had a good joke on that one"?
-I have been following --
I don't know if you guys
have been following this crazy
murder investigation
that's happening
in Massachusetts.
I know that you guys wanted
to talk about this.
[ Laughter ]
-You knew that?
-We polled the audience earlier
and they were like,
"Get into that."
-Wait, which one?
-But it was like -- it was --
it started rolling out on --
I kept seeing these
headlines on CNN.
And the first headline is like,
you know, "New Year's Day,
wife disappears.
Husband's worried."
[ Light laughter ]
And you realize
"husband worried"
should just auto-correct
to "husband murdered."
But they don't...
You can't say that yet.
-Yes, exactly.
-So, then --
Then the next one was like,
"Husband says wife took an Uber
to the airport.
Uber says no."
[ Laughter ]
So, like, already,
Uber, of all --
You know it's bad
when Uber is like,
"This guy's a little sketchy,
I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
And then the next --
-Getting a comment from Uber.
And then the next one is like,
"Husband says he took his son to
get ice cream, but footage shows
he went to Home Depot to buy
tarps and a hacksaw."
[ Laughter ]
-Wait...
-And you're like, "Whoa,
this really escalated!"
And then they were like --
then they're like,
"Alright, we're gonna
bring him in, you know,
and we're charging him
with misleading investigators."
And his attorney is like,
"What evidence do you even have
against my client?"
They're like, "Well, we found
a bloody knife in the basement."
-Yeah.
-And the guy's lawyer is like,
"Whoa, you did? Oh, my God."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, well, that's not good.
That's, like, classic
bad evidence."
-Didn't they find --
-And then the Google searches.
-Yes!
-The Google searches.
There's like hund-- They were
like, "What other evidence?"
And they had 100 Google searches
and they're literally like,
"When wife dead,
how long to inherit money?"
-Yes!
-And then, I swear to God,
one of them was,
"Top 10 ways to dispose of
a body if you really need to."
-Wow.
-He googled a top 10 list.
-He googled it. Yeah.
-He was like,
"Maybe Letterman did it."
"Maybe he could give me
some ideas on how to do it."
-This week you have Aubrey Plaza
hosting, who is very funny.
-Yeah.
-And she actually said
she interned at "SNL" --
-Yes.
...for a couple years.
-She interned.
She was in the...
She worked in our set --
the set design, like, with Leo,
and it was --
-Did you know her then?
-Yeah, we were --
we're basically the same age.
We started, like, within a year
when I started as a writer and
she started as -- in set design.
And then she became a page.
She said she got basically
demoted to being a page
from having -- running
in the set design,
working in the set design.
And so, I've known her
from since then.
And I, kind of, in my mind,
thought she had already hosted
because she's so great,
and very I'm excited
that she's doing it
for the first time.
-She's gonna crush it.
She was great in "White Lotus."
Yeah.
It's gonna be a great show.
Sam Smith, Aubrey Plaza.
Thank you for being here.
-Oh, my God. Thank you.
-Colin Jost.
Crush it. Break a leg.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks for indulging me...
-Colin Jost, everybody.
-...my trip down
the investigation.
-"Saturday Night Live" returns
tomorrow on NBC and Peacock
with host Aubrey Plaza
and musical guest Sam Smith.
Kenya Barris joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.